I think that if I don't say I'm above
average then who else is going to say it
do you know what I mean if I don't back
myself first and I don't think I'll ever
become above average I think you know
your mind is the most powerful thing and
you kind of are what you think kind of
the same as you are what you eat type
Vibes so if I don't think I'm above
average and not what I bring to the
table that I I I'm I am the
table I'm the table you know what I mean
and I might not be your table but he
might like the oak table with a wonky
leg and you know and and and a crochet
doily on top right and and he over there
might want a marble table but I will be
somebody's table